foreign
[Music]
oh man I'm too tired for this it got
cold overnight
[Music]
I mean Mariachi I think
I'm not entirely sure we're going to
explore some
some mine abandoned mine I'm recording
this in case this is my lines from long
we'll see how this goes
[Music]
what the [ __ ] look at that
it's snowing
can you see it
ah [ __ ]
I've never seen this before
whoa
watch out for this oh [ __ ]
scare PewDiePie season two
finally released
whoa
let's say
what the [ __ ]
the den
[Music]
no no look at the [ __ ] mess you've
made
no this is an atrocity I didn't do this
[Music]
all right I'll tell you this I'll tell
you this place up no problem
[ __ ]
I broke it I broke the only last thing
Swedish Man versus vacuum all right it's
not it's not going so well is it oh yeah
there is actually a plug but it leads to
just nothing like a yeah
G fuel called PewDiePie
[ __ ] he's the best in the business
Second Ride
[Music]
welcome to my home tour
500 million
dollars come along
I am really tempted to go in a bit but I
also feel like I will die
oh I gotta do it
for my brows
it's getting pretty bad season two
oh [ __ ] this
huh
I'm alive
didn't die the first second
so that was my entrance
it's like Resident Evil
when you're looking at the window and
you're supposed to look at the character
letters and then do you know what I mean
you bet I did
that thing freaks me out I don't know
what it is
what is this
I need to know what the [ __ ] is it it's
a bunny they hung the bunny
no
[Laughter]
why did someone do this
we gotta take her down
there's something down though yeah
[Music]
Christ is now taking me to another
abandoned place no
damn this is so pretty wow
[Music]
it's a face do you see it
that's the phase I would make if I was a
man
Chris has taken me on another date
location
are you gonna propose here
that's a fine Gorge
like
just these houses they're just a massive
Gorge it's amazing shop to the middle
my ass walking with her tail up
oh she just had to be
been a bit worried about Maya lately
because
um
yeah sometimes she's not good and
it's nice to see that she's happy to
walk at least
yeah I don't think she has that much
left so it's almost like
stressful
[Music]
okay
[Music]
yeah we're just going to check out oh
thank you so much yeah
take care
there she is
there
that's so nice unsynchronizing
[Music]
I'm probably the only mad lion getting a
cold drink today
I have no idea what I ordered some kind
of coffee
[Music]
all right
bye
bye
what do we have over there
hello
did we have a good nap
how are we doing here
I did it again look at these fools
where's this guy thinks we're friends
I try to push him down but then he tried
to push me down
and then he fell down
[Music]
this guy wasn't having it almost
go to my third victim
me and the Among Us guy was teaming up
last round so I wasn't going for him but
he died so
foreign
[Music]
I found him
he's in Japan guys
go to you Merry Christmas
we're in there real fungi for the
Christmas Market got some pretzels can I
try it
that was the smallest bite it was good
very Christmas like here I like it
[Music]
that's a space-time Christmas tree
foreign
[Music]
wiggle yours
damn that's a wiggly cake yeah
they lit up the Tokyo Tower like a
Christmas tree
that's so cool
[Music]
so pretty look at the illuminations
it's coming out we don't have time to
stop so we're just gonna drive through
it and everyone enjoy the footage now
thank you
[Music]
are you tired now
I like this angle
[Music]
that's where she used to sit
she may have passed away a lot last
morning it's been tough
I miss her so much
we got her when as long as I've been
with mercy and like we got her so early
when I was in Sweden
I didn't have any money back then like I
I was at the start of my YouTube
and we scrambled together everything we
had
and she caused just as much as as we had
left like it was it was almost fate that
we found that dog I feel like because
we didn't have a car either and this dog
happened to be like walking distance and
Maya was cheaper because she only had
one eye
but we didn't we didn't care
it's just 11 years ago yeah looking back
it was kind of crazy getting a dog but
even though me and Marge had hadn't even
been together a full year yet but
it was the best decision ever to get
Maya
she was such a sweet dog I almost could
I almost couldn't believe it when we had
her because I thought for sure buying an
older dog
because she was six years then you know
what's wrong with her like why would you
give away this dog and I I couldn't
believe it when I got to know her
because she was such a sweet dog
she was so gentle and so kind and never
caused any problem I just couldn't
believe anyone would want to part with
the dog like that
she was such a huge part of our Lives
you know we had so many great memories
together I remember especially in Sweden
when she played in the snow such a good
memory so many good memories
we took her everywhere
she she did get dementia and I talked
about that and it's been really
difficult to see her sort of slowly
digress and we did everything we could
to make her as good as we could but it
wasn't it wasn't enough in the end we
sacrificed so much just to take care of
her but looking back I don't regret any
of it I'm so glad we did
she deserved it oh yeah I'm gonna miss
ow
it's been a couple days now since Maya
passed away it's been heavy you know she
was a family member we're both doing
much better
we're healing
but it is it it's been very tough anger
is fine a lot of people were worried
about anger
um
you know Maya hasn't been herself and
for so long you know so I'm glad that
gay isn't bothered and it's been nice to
have it Garen Momo if they've been
making us laugh
cheering us out I wrote down all my
thoughts that really helped get some
clarity and working out really hell
clear my head
every day is just a little easier
everyone's been so sweet online as well
which we both me and might say really
appreciate
it's nice to know that that so many
people care and we've been we've been on
too many highs you know moving to Japan
everything has just been so amazing when
life goes up and life goes down
this is how it is
I am really thankful that we did get our
time with her here these seven months
and yeah I'm just glad for that where do
they will come
they've been going for the past 20
minutes guys it's a draw okay
okay Mama
oh are you admitting the Feet Again
I am almost losing it
it all started over the toy
[Music]
no no
drop drop
let it
it's not lunch time yet
foreign
[Music]
making rice pudding no wait what is it
called in English it's Swedish Christmas
today on the 24th good evening everyone
well it's kind of our tradition now too
but we I always did it as a kid
for Christmas morning you put an almond
in then in it and whoever gets the
almond
guess like to open a gift early or a
special treat so you want the all
Guardian gamers
oh that's good it came out perfect yes
you got the element you win Christmas
[Music]
are we a little crazy
you're on your back what are you gonna
do
you look evil
something
what are you doing we played so much
today okay
[Music]
recent bathing
in your new sweater looking good
as well again no more
[Music]
we're stuck in traffic
there's been two accidents unfortunately
so it's taking a bit longer but we're
getting there
[Music]
momoy's about to do
her first coupon sign stop eating dirt
you weirdo
come on you can do it
poop
I know you have to poop
why
did you eat that dirt
huh why did you do it
we stopped that end Outlet
and it's so busy so now it's New Year's
coming up shoga says so a lot of people
take holiday off since they don't get
much
holiday
we didn't expect this many people nice
weather
but no snow so far
we're on the hunt I'm not entirely sure
where we are
oh God there's all these Teslas waiting
to be cherished
you see
we're charged
and so it's Tesla oh you were sleeping
oh so cute
we had dog mode on in the car
I have so many questions Japan
and I need answers
we have still 53 minutes gone it's
taking forever
we're not leaving the we have to enter
the freeway and it's taking so long
[Music]
we found this now
it's there oh God is this snow
I've never seen that what is that
what
oh they have a snow warning
[Music]
after a long train ride with the
shinkansen
we have a ride
at Nico station
so pretty
[Music]
you probably can't see it but it is
snowing like an iny beanie tiny bit
it never really snowed in UK when we
lived there
maybe like once twice I don't know
because we're lived by the Seacoast
Seacoast
oh I know what she's doing because I was
doing the same thing
don't even think about it
you were close too bad you died now Mike
Sam
this is perfect snow all right
no more
[Music]
we're going to shinkyo bridge it's
supposed to be very pretty and we get
the Sun so we should be
prayed again
looking good in your sweater
it looks like it's a little tiny for you
[Music]
having a good time Mama
a little cold
I was actually invited here
by the mayor of gunma
it's snowing like one snowflake oh
actually someone
[Music]
thank you
you're popular Mama
it's so pretty here right Iggy in Winter
they have hot versions of the drinks
oh it's warm
what the hell
there you go Momo I got you covered
British in it what
that's so odd we made it to the temple
I think
maybe I think it's one of them I think
there's two what a pretty fountain look
at you Mama
[Music]
hey guy
you're not allowed here
so it's actually a little close so
there's no one here which is really nice
these type of lanterns make everything
so cozy
I don't know what it is
but it works
I love it
oh you saw the snow there you saw it I'm
not lying
this is so pretty here
I love it
it's getting dark so fast
I think we only have time for the temple
should be over here
check it out what is that why is there a
comparison to the giant Tower
what a troll why would they do that
is that Sky Tree yeah Skytree and
the five-stored Pagoda wait where we are
now yeah
oh I'm so dumb I thought it was like a
meme like look how tiny our Pagoda is
okay where's hayabus Sky Tree got it
what do you think
[Music]
[Music]
you just woke up
you sound like I can't move